here's an ice cream
actually we have the ice cream on the
top and this is called the cone
and it's one of the three dimensional
shapes we will look at
it looks something like this and when
inverted will look like this
whenever you see a three-dimensional
figure you just have to ask yourself two
questions
what is the figure made of and how is it
defined
the cone has one circular base and a
slant curved surface
the slant curved surface begins at the
vertex
and grows towards the base the next
thing we need to know is how a cone is
defined
a cone is defined by two parameters
first its height and second the radius
of its circular base
this length will be the height and this
length will be the radius of the
circular base
so if both these parameters are given we
will get a unique cone
what does this mean say you're asked to
draw a cone which has the radius of its
circular base
5 centimeters so you draw it like this
well some of you may draw it like this
or maybe like this
the radius of the circular base is the
same in each case
but to define it uniquely we need the
height too now let's analyze an inverted
cone
if we take the circular base out we will
be left with a hollow open cone
now if we tear open the cone vertically
from the vertex
this is how it will look and now
if we just open this up a bit more this
is how it will look
and guess what this is it is a sector of
a circle
so the curved surface of a cone when
opened up
looks like a sector of a circle
you